Fiji water when we purchase Fiji water
about three or four years ago they have
the square bottle
they had different packaging different
graphics on the on the packaging and
they're a unique selling proposition if
you will their slogan was a taste of
paradise but when I became involved in
that water business when we made the
purchase and it was up to me to review
the marketing see what I wanted to keep
and what I wanted to change I did a lot
of research in the water business and I
found out that 55 percent of the water
out there is actually from the tap the
Dasani and Aquafina of the world are tap
water from the municipal water system
that are then purified and put in a
bottle and then you have spring water
like Evian and waters like that that
that are almost on the surface you know
they come from an underground spring but
they're on the surface and then we have
this water that we were selling they
came from an underground aquifer the
water fellas rained 200 years ago and
went through this volcanic rock and
picked up silica and the electrolytes in
the fluoride and so forth and was
protected by this volcanic rock and the
only way to get to the water was to put
a borehole through and have the water
come through hermetically sealed pipes
and so our unique selling proposition
our personality became untouched until
you drink it is that waters been
untouched for all these years and that
was really set us apart from a taste of
paradise you could say about any water
that came from any remote area but
untouched until you drink it we're
probably the only people in the world
that can say that
well palm certainly has a personality
that little bottle shaped like me you
may have noticed we make that bottle the
person so you relate to that bottle now
the thing about palm is that it's backed
with all this peer-reviewed science it
really is health in a bottle it's not
just a juice it's it's full of
polyphenol antioxidants it's great for
your circulation it's good for men to
ward off prostate cancer it's forty
percent as effective as viagra
it's got fabulous attributes Alzheimer's
prenatal birth defects I mean on and on
all of that is on our website and we
continue with our scientific research
but there's only so much you can say in
advertising but when you see that little
bottle with a noose around its neck
that's cut and it says cheat death
you really empathize with the bottle and
with all of the attributes or for every
young word has a hula-hoop that it's
trying to keep up or whatever
and the personality of the brand is kind
of sassy but charming it's your friend